treating ailments using alternative
medicines
but with most people in lebanon affected
by three years of economic crisis the
practice is becoming more popular
today the demand is increasing because
the price of medicine is too high i used
to have five to six customers a day now
i have up to 15.
herbal remedies are commonly much
cheaper than medications especially
after the government stopped subsidies
poverty is particularly high in the
northern city of tripoli
people are resorting to such treatments
even for serious diseases
charity workers like fat maduna is
buying herbs to substitute diabetes
medication that's become unaffordable
for many
politicians blamed for the crisis have
done nothing to reverse the economic
collapse
many people can't afford a simple
medication like nexium they buy herbs to
treat heartbanks
a lack of dollars means lebanon can't
import all the drugs its people need
ali
i can't afford the medicine that i used
to buy i'm buying the cheaper ones made
in lebanon and syria
pharmacists tell us there is no way of
knowing the efficacy of alternative
products
nearly 35 percent of households can't
afford health care the public health
sector is struggling to keep up with the
growing demand as fewer people have the
money to pay for private hospitals
the ministry says at least 70 percent of
the population are demanding help but
its budget isn't high enough
people reach the doors of the hospital
and they die because hospitals demand
cash in dollars
most people including health care
workers are paid in the local currency
the lebanese pound that's devalued and
the health system wants the best in the
region is crumbling
we can't secure enough medicine for
cancer and kidney dialysis patients we
can't give them the three sessions they
need every week
doctors say the accelerating crisis has
reached a point where patients lives are
at risk senator al-jazeera tripoli
northern lebanon